this is a production hi there my name is
zachary stancil i am the hemp germplasm
curator at the plant genetic resources
unit
which is a part of the national plant
germplasm system which is in turn part
of the agricultural research service
which is part of the usda
my background i'm a recent graduate from
cornell horticulture where i primarily
focused on brassica oloracia crops
specifically broccoli
my work was done in support of the
eastern broccoli project which is a
10-year study um
breeding developing
broccoli hybrids adapted for
i'm really excited to tell you about the
conditions
so we are in a
one of the plant genetic resources unit
greenhouse
in beautiful geneva new york where we
maintain
a wide variety of different vegetable
crop collections so we
have about 20 000
accessions that are comprised of about
300 unique species
just like the other vegetable crop
collections held at pgru
we don't actively participate in plant
breeding rather we
function to collect conserve
characterize and distribute these
materials so that's what we'll do with
hemp as well
so
we're acquiring materials from uh
many different sources a lot of our
initial donors are going to be
university level or private breeding
companies that are working with hemp
germplasm um we the regulatory
definition exclusively
is given in the 2020 hemp final rule
which is defined essentially as
less than 0.3 percent thc by dry weight
um so so those are the materials that we
will uh collect
increase characterize and distribute um
so
much of the work that we do here will
follow a very similar pipeline to how we
would for example deal with the allium
crops brassica crops tomato collections
as well so we maintain these germplasm
collections for a couple reasons one to
simply just conserve
the uh crop genetic diversity of these
many different crops
and then secondly we're a working germ
plasma repository so we make these
materials available
to
many different stakeholders so npgs
stakeholders are typically
plant breeders people doing basic
science research educators
um and they use these materials to
map important genetic traits or
breed locally or climate change adapted
lines
so
all of these factors are very much true
for hemp which is um
really
this is the the dawn of domestic hemp
research so
um having a vast collection of diverse
hemp germ plasm is going to be really
fundamental in laying the foundation for
powerful research
in the decades to come
so hemp is a crop that has been known
since ancient history
nomadic tribes people in central asia
used it extensively
there's strong evidence to believe that
it was
this distributed along the silk road to
east asia valued as a
really many different areas
as a medicinal crop um
the the uses are almost hard to
enumerate
so hemp has been an incredibly important
crop in
the united states history in fact the 10
dollar bill used to depict a scene of
farmers harvesting hemp for fiber crops
so
the usda produces
collection that included nearly 300
sessions
that collection was lost um and so this
work is picking up on that effort um
unfortunately we won't be able to
recover many of those materials but
there's a a lot of genetic diversity
that that exists in the world it very
much remains to be seen what the role of
hemp will be in domestic and global
production
but it's also extremely exciting
to
imagine the scope of possibilities that
hemp materials could
be able to address so hemp is a very
multi-purpose crop it's used for
fiber grain oil
it produces highly diverse
secondary plant metabolites that we're
only just beginning to understand the
scale and scope of that could be
critical for medicinal uses or
other
phytochemical applications
the techniques that we're using on our
basic research side so
mpgs and plant genetics resource unit is
first and foremost a service
organization
like i said we exist to conserve these
materials and then provide them to
the public so
in the meantime we do in fact do some
some basic research although that
um
typically comes secondary to
that mission that i spoke of
so in terms of hemp
we're really trying to catch up on lost
time
this is a project that
should have been
in place for 70 years
so i'm trying to very rapidly bring this
germplasm collection up to speed with
for example the tomato collection or the
apple collection which we also keep here
um so what that looks like is initially
i'm trying to understand the
genetic and geographical diversity of
the broader pool of hemp germplasm we
have a lot of pieces of information
i've done a lot of work trying to
assemble them together build a database
of literature
online resources interviews with hemp
readers in other countries
um
assemble that all together
to help me gain a more comprehensive
picture of the broader pool of hemp
germplasm
secondly
i formed a number of really vital
collaborations
um to assist in this project so
my role will be primarily to
collect increase characterize and
distribute these materials
which will be made available on the
gren global
portal online which is an online
database that allows users to query
germplasm
and make requests so this tool also
allows us to collect and aggregate
large amounts of phenotypic or trait
data
so
these collaborations that i formed
will
leverage
capabilities in other areas to collect
and screen these materials that we'll be
collecting and distributing so for
example
i've been working closely with a lab
that characterizes cotton and flax fiber
i can send them materials from artwork
they can characterize it for fiber
traits
i will take that data and add it to the
grin global database
to make it publicly available
i formed
additional collaborations with
analytical labs that will be
characterizing secondary plant
metabolites
as well as working with some
groups
where we plan to
screen these materials for morphological
and plant architectural diversity
so the goal is to not only assemble a
diverse collection of hemp genetics but
a robust high dimensional set of
phenotypic data that will accompany
those materials
this is a brand new program so we don't
have a lot of historical context a lot
of this work was made
possible by
provisions in the 2014 and 2018 farm
bill
and some
subsequent legislation that really laid
the groundwork for this type of project
to even exist
for me i feel like i'm breaking new
ground every day there's so much to
learn there's so many questions to
resolve
navigating a
complex
legal topography has been challenging
so
uh the the
for me
i feel like i'm on many steep learning
curves at once but that's also exciting
and where i love to be
this work has provided me an opportunity
to ask many basic fundamental questions
about him scaling expertise from other
areas experts who
evaluate fiber quality and flax
flax is a crop that requires redding
similar to hemp
so
what are what does the literature say
about this what are techniques applied
to him that are the flax that may be
applicable to him
those types of questions um
hops is genetically relatively close
relative to cannabis
so
are there is there knowledge from
pathology work done by hop breeders or
hot pathologists that can be applied to
screening
cannabis germplasm for disease
resistance
um
another accomplishment that i'm pretty
proud of is
i've been working with as many people as
i can bring in together to develop a
hemp phenotypic descriptor manual
so this
will ultimately be a comprehensive
and
complete resource to allow
the hemp community to compare apples to
apples how do you measure
plant height what is the best sampling
technique for
cannabinoids what is the
best way to assay fiber quality those
sorts of things putting them all
together into one combined pdf
that will allow
breeders and researchers to
simply compare phenotypic traits across
genetically and geographically diverse
germplasm i think would be a great value
to the hemp community and i've been
really excited to
speak to the real experts
get their thoughts get their opinions
pull information out of papers compare
them side by side and assemble this hemp
descriptor's manual and ultimately i
hope that that information will be used
to
develop very specific mapping
populations that allow us to tease apart
the
genetic foundations of
key
hemp
horticulture agronomic traits
so
work that i see long term in the future
i would love to
gain a deeper understanding of this
wider pool of hemp genetic diversity
and work with many collaborators to
build that into a hemp magic population
that segregates for
many critical traits and captures the
the larger pool of hemp diversity i
think that would be
an enormously valuable resource that i'd
love to offer to
public and private plant breeders as
well as those working to map plant
traits
so as far as what the future holds
first and foremost i just want to add
more
diverse hemp genetic materials to our
collection while collecting as much
phenotypic data to accompany those
materials at the same time so that's
kind of goal number one is just to scale
build
um
our collection
i would also like to improve our ability
to produce a lot of high quality seed
hemp is
a very challenging crop it's dioecious
it's wind pollinated so a lot of our
typical
greenhouse
seed increase procedures are not
applicable in the same way pollen
control is of vital importance
so developing methods to
handle those challenges
will be
ongoing
project i'm also really interested in
developing new collaborations and
partnerships
um i i think it's exciting that hemp is
such a diverse crop that's applicable to
so many different
industries and groups and stakeholders
that i'd love to
help harness the power of hemp's
incredible genetic diversity
to enable those diverse research
projects so please feel feel free to
reach out to me if you have some great
ideas
another long-term goal is to develop a
core diversity collection
what's a
reduced set of hemp germplasm that can
be used to capture
succinctly the range of population
structure that exist within cannabis
[Music]
so there's also many many many more
things that i'm excited about and look
forward to in the future
but that's
that's probably enough to keep me busy
for a few years
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu